STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
It's Stephanie Wong,
Cloud Developer Advocate.
And today I have, again,
Google fellow Eric Brewer.
Here, we have him doing
a series of videos.
We hope that you have
enjoyed them so far.
But Eric, we are both
so excited for this one,
because we are gathering our
questions from the community.
ERIC BREWER: I am
looking forward to this.
It is true.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
So we have both put out
a prompt for questions.
And this is meant for
anything that you've
been curious about
around Eric's work
over the last decade,
any advice that you've
had for our next
generation of developers,
especially in the
Kubernetes space.
So first off, the first
question that we've gathered
is, can we make
use of Kubernetes
in the edge, namely the
Raspberry API devices,
where security can
be a big challenge?
ERIC BREWER: Well, people are
definitely using Kubernetes
at the edge, mostly in the telco
space and the retail space.
Certainly, some
well-known large customers
actually run Kubernetes clusters
in each of their big stores.
So it's definitely in
use in the edge today.
It also runs on Raspberry
Pi, so that it's not, per se,
new either, although that
is a more constrained way
to run, for sure.
The implicit question,
though, that it's less secure,
I would say is neither
true nor false.
I would say Kubernetes
has certainly an option
to be quite secure, as
secure as other things based
on, say, traditional VMs.
However, it really comes
down to the whole stack.
So what is the security of
your hardware, for example?
Do you have any root of
trust in that hardware?
Google servers that we
put in our data centers
actually have a hidden
key deep inside so
that we actually know we're
running on a real server.
We know that the
BIOS is trusted.
We know that the OS is trusted.
So we build up a trusted
stack and run on that.
That's historically
harder to do at the edge,
but it's still a good goal.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Increasingly important as
well, especially given the work
that you are doing
around bringing security
to this Kubernetes
and open-source era.
Now, what about data?
So we have another question
about what Kubernetes
would look like in the--
I'm assuming data
analytics space.
Currently, data applications
are relatively Cloud-specific.
ERIC BREWER:
Certainly, Kubernetes
started with less focus
on data and more focus
on services, especially
stateless services.
Those are the easiest to
do for lots of reasons.
And that goes, again,
back to the '90s.
That's a basic principle.
But everyone is
building data services
on communities now
of many flavors,
and it is certainly possible
now to do a good job of that.
But I think the question
sounds like it's more about,
how do we have the same
kind of revolution for data
that containers brought to
computing or services brought
to computing?
And that is a great question,
and it's not easily answered.
But I think the service is
a good framing for that,
meaning that when
I talk about data,
it's not just the actual data.
It's probably, what
are the methods,
to use the
object-oriented paradigm,
or the APIs around that data?
Because if I have an API
view in my data, then
I also start to
talk about policy,
who can read it,
who can write it,
access control kinds of things.
Maybe I can force other
policies like data locality.
This data needs to stay
in Europe, for example.
So I do think we need
a bit better packaging
of the data itself and
the wrapper around it.
And I would say this
group is exploring that.
But I would say
that's still to be.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
this is related,
but I think there's also
an increasing need for more
processing power to do things
like machine learning, data
analytics,
high-performance computing.
So what is the future for
co-processors in the Kubernetes
space, like using
GPUs, TPUs, et cetera?
ERIC BREWER:
Co-processors in general
are an important part
of any computing future.
We're at the end of
Moore's law, in the sense
that general-purpose
computing is not getting
as fast as it used to per year.
The rate of change is slower.
It's just too bad for all of us.
One of the few ways you
can make up for that
is to have more
domain-specific hardware.
That's what a TPU
is, for TensorFlow.
That's what a GPU is, both for
graphics, and it's used for AI.
So accelerators
are here to stay.
And in fact, you can use both
TPUs and GPUs from Kubernetes.
There's nothing, per
se, wrong with that.
I would say there's a new
offering of Kubernetes on GKE
where you can actually subdivide
a GPU into smaller pieces,
so that it's actually easier to
use a small amount particularly
for inference, or to use
a large amount if you
want to do training.
But absolutely, that is part of
the core future of Kubernetes.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And it's been incredible to
see the extension and the usage
of Kubernetes in the
machine-learning space,
especially with open-source
platforms like Qflow
and what we've built
into Vertex AI.
So it's really exciting,
and I'm looking forward
to seeing where we start
to implement those things.
Now, this question is a common
question that I think we get.
But talking about
on-premise private clouds
versus public
clouds, to you, what
is the right balance between
open public cloud and private,
closed, sovereign
clouds for companies?
ERIC BREWER: That's a
very tricky question,
which many countries
are worried about.
So the short answer
is, you'd be better off
with an open public
cloud pretty much
all the time if you can use
one, because it will have better
cost efficiency, will have
a higher rate of innovation.
It can do more things over time.
However, that means you must not
only trust your cloud provider,
but you also have to
trust the government that
runs the country which your
cloud provider is based,
which for most of us is the US.
So if you're a country that is
worried about the US government
you may decide, that at least
some of your workloads--
that's too risky, and
you really want them
running in your own country.
That's where the
word "sovereign"
comes from in these contexts.
Now, the good news
is, something that's
based on open source
like Kubernetes
is amenable to running
well in private cloud.
That's a big part
of Anthos, which
is something I've
worked on, also,
for both hybrid and multi-cloud.
So you'll see us
talking about sovereign
in terms of our general
open cloud extension,
because at least that means
you can use Kubernetes on GKE.
And if for some reason you need
to exit, for whatever reason
you can run Kubernetes on-prem,
and at least your workloads
will be movable.
Now, is it trivial
to do that no.
But it doesn't
have to be trivial.
It just has to be possible.
STEPHANIE WONG: Absolutely.
It's a tough space.
But it's going to
continue to evolve over
time as our geopolitical
climate changes.
So it's a lot to
think about now.
Now, many, many great
tech, including Kubernetes
and BigQuery, as you know, came
from internal Google technology
that we've decided
to externalize.
So I think the
community is curious,
but what is the next big
thing that we are hoping to
or we think we
might externalize?
ERIC BREWER: Well, I
think it just happened,
but people didn't
realize it, which
is Google has great internal
solutions for supply chain
security.
We've written papers on it.
VCID is the internal name.
I don't know what it stands
for, but basically, it's
a set of invariants
about how our software is
built, such that
we can prove things
about it before it operates.
For example, we can
prove internally
that every piece of
code is in our repo
and that multiple people
have looked at that code
to make sure that it's safe.
And those are strong
safeties to be able to make,
and we can make them internally.
Now, to externalize that is kind
of like externalizing Bigtable.
We didn't actually release
the actual Bigtable code.
If we had, no one
could have used it,
because it had a lot of
dependencies on internal Google
stuff.
So we wrote a paper.
People wrote versions
of it externally,
leading to HSPACE
and other things.
That's one model.
The equivalent here is SLSA,
which is now part of OpenSSF,
where this is a
framework for how
to think about supply chain.
But the good news is, it's
based on what we actually
have been doing internally for,
I think, at least 10 years.
And we already know
where it's in production.
So like Bigtable, it's
proven in production.
We actually externalize
it with the community.
Because again, we need to
have buy-in on how it works.
It needs to be done
in an appropriate way
for open source, which
is not that easy.
Hence, need some discussion.
That process is going on now.
People absolutely are
welcome to contribute.
It'll also be a big part
of the executive order
as we move towards
secure supply chains
in general for the nation.
STEPHANIE WONG: Exactly.
It can't be done in a vacuum.
And we are inviting
the community
to help us bring these
things to the broader
industry as a whole.
So that is a great
note to end on, Eric.
I know that you have shared
your time with us over the span
of this video series.
So I just want to thank you so
much for sharing your knowledge
and your experience.
ERIC BREWER: My pleasure.
And great to be
involved in this way.
Thank you so much.
STEPHANIE WONG:
For everybody else,
we hope that you enjoyed
this video series.
Let us know if you
want more like this.
And if you do have thoughts,
comments, questions, concerns,
jokes, check us out on social.
Reach out to us on Twitter.
We'll include our handles here.
Thank you so much, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]